Ciao a tutti Allora
questa è una sessione tedesca e quindi
dovrebbe iniziare con una slide di
questo tipo ho un grande sogno
effettivamente parleremo di una speranza
che coltivo da 10 anni ma in realtà
parleremo di denaro e di come
guadagnarlo meglio che argomento vile
potreste dire voi dopo tutti questi bei
discorsi e in realtà secondo me come
facciamo denaro e in che modo lo
guadagniamo dice un sacco della nostra
cultura e della società in cui viviamo
Allora la speranza da cui parte è questa
un giorno vendere il proprio tempo sarà
scandaloso inaccettabile
riprovevole Come vendere le persone la
schiavitù Ok questa è la tesi di base
Spero nel prossimo quarto d'ora di
convincervi almeno di ispirarvi a fare
ricerca in questo senso autonomamente
Allora io sono arrivato a questa
conclusione quando alla terza esperienza
imprenditoriale mi rendevo conto che ero
felicissimo di avere completato
finalmente quella transizione dal dai
contratti a corpo non importa che lavoro
facessi Basta che non facciate gli
operai in catena manifatturiera perché
sia valido questo discorso tra l'altro
anche con tutto il rispetto per gli
operai in aula benissimo
e quindi mi ero reso conto che ero
felice di essere passato dai contratti
basati su un prezzo fisso su una stima
Quanto ci metti Quanto ci vuole Qual è
il prezzo Entro quando lo consegni
sapete no architetti fotografi editori
un sacco di lavori sono basati su questa
dinamica e tutti questi lavoratori
cercano proprio vedono come un miraggio
la possibilità di vendere le ore le
giornate le settimane così oh la loro 6
ore me pagano 6 ore se lavoro tre ore ne
pagano tre ore l'accento Romano
evidentemente Rivera il fatto che non
sono di Bolzano ma serve anche per come
dire per eventuali effetti retorici il
problema è che anche in quel caso si
rivelò essere ancora una volta non tutto
oro quello che
e vendere tempo crea un'illusione di
sicurezza che in realtà è
direbbero Gli anglosassoni Self di
feeding Si si sconfigge da sola Si è
auto e autolesionista e vediamo perché
vorrei piazzare un punto chiaro su
questo su questo su questo argomento
Allora innanzitutto vendere tempo Setta
stabilisce dei limiti
per noi per la nostra ricchezza per la
possibilità di generare ricchezza nella
nostra vita Innanzitutto abbiamo solo 24
ore al giorno siamo d'accordo poi non
possiamo lavorarne 24 anche il più
stacanovista dei Lavoratori Comunque
deve dormire deve mangiare
auspicabilmente avrà delle relazioni
sociali Per non parlare di quelle
sentimentali e poi comunque proprio
nello cioè bisogna prendere un autobus
Ogni tanto ho capito il telelavoro
cellulare eccetera eccetera ma in
generale non sono 24 ore al giorno anche
se fossero 24 comunque ci sarebbe il
problema di venderne dopo averne venduto
da 24° la 25ª e a quel punto qui
qualcuno potrebbe obiettare Ah ma che
c'entra alzi il valore Anzi la tariffa e
guadagni di più anche se fai solo 8 ore
eh Ma signori e signore signore questo
sarebbe un argomento a favore della mia
tesi quella persona avrebbe trovato un
modo di eh avvalorare apprezzare di
dimostrare un valore ehm ulteriore per
ogni proprio minuto per ogni proprio ora
E quindi avrebbe comunque all'interno
del modo di spiegare perché un'ora oggi
vale più di una sua ora un anno fa bene
In più c'è un altro problema quando
lavoriamo con vendendo il tempo di fatto
ci esponiamo a delle asimmetrie negative
come le chiamerebbe una SIM taleb autore
di anti fragile sostanzialmente
significa vi faccio un esempio pratico
siete mai stati puniti per aver
consegnato un lavoro in ritardo Non per
forza con una penale ma almeno con una
con un rimprovero la risposta in
generale è Sì vedo qualcuno a annuire
pochi però devi vedere un bel mondo
nessuno vi rimprovera per consegnare in
ritardo eh Il problema è che raramente
gli accordi di lavoro prevedono un
premio per Chi consegna prima e
addirittura arriviamo al paradosso per
cui a parità Eh Come direbbero gli
avvocati visto che parliamo di accordi
di lavoro cederi sparibus a parità di
altre condizioni Chi vende lo stesso
lavoro in tre ore se la tariffa è la
stessa di un'altra persona che finisce
quel lavoro in 6 ore per assurdo la
prima persona fattura la metà della
seconda per cui Scusate di nuovo a
romanesco ricorro ma eh Ma se te lo
porto prima se te lo consegno Prima
voglio essere pagato di più andiamo
avanti
a questo punto scatta proprio una
dinamica di
avversione alle perdite si chiama Nel
gergo delle Scienze cognitive e ci
ritroviamo a dire ancora un altro Sì per
citare Fiorella Mannoia per cui ogni ora
che non riusciamo a vendere abbiamo
l'ansia di non averla venduta E l'essere
umano come molti animali vive peggio la
perdita di un'ora non venduta che il
guadagno di un'ora venduta questo vi
invito a leggere pensieri lenti e veloci
di Daniel caneman è un libro fondante
per questi per questi argomenti che non
tratteremo oggi il punto è stiamo lì
Siccome abbiamo 8 ore al giorno 9 10
Dipende da quanto siete fortunati però
il punto è stiamo lì ognuno Ah oddio Uh
dobbiamo dobbiamo dobbiamo trovare un
altro cliente trova un altro commessa
trova un altro progetto però questa cosa
per assurdo si accompagna in maniera del
tutto contraddittoria con quest'altro
fenomeno la paura della domanda in
eccesso
Io ho un sacco di clienti
che alla notizia o abbiamo un cliente in
più
E adesso come facciamo cioè come può
essere che diventa un problema per
un'altra persona che bussa la tua porta
per chiederti tieni il mio denaro
è una un paradosso legato al fatto che
vendiamo il tempo e quindi ci rendiamo
conto che questa risorsa scarsa il tempo
che passa per tutti i modi
incondizionato poveri ricchi bravi i
netti un'ora passa per tutti questo
tempo che io vi sto chiedendo passerà
per tutti noi mi dispiace se poi alla
fine non sarà soddisfacente Spero di no
quindi il punto è evidentemente questa
scarsità si accompagna con la paura
dell'Abbondanza è un paradosso
incredibile e poi questo proprio io
parlo di queste cose dal 2012 Ma la
pandemia mi ha servito sul piatto
d'argento un sacco di argomenti che già
portavano nel 2019
vendere il tempo ci costringe ad un
obbligo di presenza può non essere una
presenza nello spazio ma da Einstein in
poi spazio tempo sono cose come dire più
correlate E se io devo essere davanti a
un monitor uno schermo perché qualcuno
deve sapere che io sto spendendo quel
tempo per lui per lei evidentemente
quello è un limite Eccoci qua alla
nostra libertà non disponiamo più
improvvisamente lo ha detto qualcuno
oggi del nostro tempo che è la risorsa
principale di ogni lavoratore di ogni
individuo di ogni persona lo dico con le
parole di Alan Weiss il tempo
discrezionale è la risorsa strategica
principale di ogni essere umano tempo
discrezionali significa non il tempo
libero ma la discrezione la possibilità
di allocare quel tempo nelle attività
che voglio incluse le vacanze
notate bene lo smart Working il lavoro
in remoto a distanza o ancora meglio
asincrono sono diverse gradazioni del
Lavoro sano e virtuoso ha solo allungato
la catena ma non ha sciolto da questa
schiavitù tutti noi
posso lavorare da una spia l'ho fatto
sono stato a Lanzarote tre giorni fa ma
in alcuni momenti dovevo essere come
dire ben incastrato fra una tavola da
surf e le dovute videoconferenze avevo
sbagliato mi sono organizzato male avrei
dovuto organizzarmi in maniera diversa
visto che vi sto parlando di quest'oggi
ma per dirvi che sbaglio anch'io eh Non
è che sta salendo in cattedra e poi
incredibile Mi hanno rubato la slide
sugli umarell C'è l'effetto Marel
per cui che succede succede che se noi
vendiamo il tempo legittimiamo il nostro
cliente a chiederci e rendere conto e a
obbligarci a rendere conto di come
passiamo quel tempo ama e perché stai
facendo questo Copy stai facendo oppure
perché stai pulendo gli obiettivi della
macchina fotografica Sbrigati Io voglio
che tu faccia foto non che tu faccia
ricerca su in biblioteca per le foto
famose in cui Sostanzialmente
autorizziamo i clienti a mettere in
discussione come lavoriamo che
sinceramente sono proprio a fare i miei
se io ti consegno valore come lavoro
sono affari miei ma è giusto che loro
controllino come passiamo il tempo se ci
pagano ora per ora lo capite lo stiamo
utilizzando noi questo comportamento
e quindi
questo lato nostro lato fornitori c'è
anche un altro aspetto
io non voglio vendere il mio tempo
perché voglio permettere adesso la
traduco questa frase per chi non è a suo
agio con l'inglese ma
Io voglio fare proprio questo principio
descritto da cui io vorrei che le
persone che hanno bisogno di me possono
possano ricorrere al mio aiuto Senza
doversi chiedere se ogni telefonata che
mi fanno sia un investimento legittimo
meno il che notate bene è un regalo che
io faccio alla mia clientela Io voglio
che loro Possano dire Jacopo cioè
la mia azienda di Jacopo c'è un po' come
i ristoranti All you can eat Chi è che
alzi la mano che gode ai ristoranti All
you can eat
c'è da abbastanza quella sensazione là
non è Ah che faccio Chiamo ancora Perché
un'altra ora poi scatta il tassametro no
figliuolo viene a me caro cliente io
lavorerò per te comunque finché le
generiamo valore Quindi occhio eh non è
che mi faccio chiamare Ehm mi sentivo
solo ok Non è così quindi il vendere
tempo è un problema per i lavoratori per
i clienti Eh ma anche poi a questo punto
Chi sono i clienti e se siete impiegati
è il vostro capo il vostro capo è la
persona che
fruisce del valore che si suppone che il
vostro stipendio compri
e accanto a voi oltre al capo ci sono
anche i colleghi un sacco di lavori sono
pensati per essere di supporto ai
colleghi Pensate ai dipartimenti Legal
Pensate ai dipartimenti di char risorse
umane gli uffici acquisti
e quindi tutto questo discorso vale
anche per chi ha impiegato e È
incredibile Quante persone sono
impiegate e non riescono a immaginare il
proprio lavoro in termini di valori
generato invece che di tempo passato Ed
è una colpa non colpa perché il mondo
del lavoro è strutturato in questo modo
c'è un cartellino che dice Tu stai qui
dalle 9 alle 5 Poi se non hai creato
valore L'importante è che tu sia stato
fino alle 5 c'è stato un capo quando
sono io sono stato dipendente Anche in
alcuni tratti della mia vita c'è stato
un capo che mi ha rimproverato che io ho
automatizzato troppo in tasca e alle
15:00 avevo finito e Jacopo può tenere
quindi c'ha le 17 non fai più niente ma
effettivamente non sappiamo cosa farti
fare Quindi lei mi sta dicendo che devo
essere meno efficiente e ridacchiando eh
Un po' sì mi sono licenziato la
settimana dopo
però capite che sono questi paradossi
che vengono generati da questo grave
equivoco iniziale concepire il valore
del nostro lavoro solo nei termini del
tempo che ci vuole un po' quella viene
anche manifestato da quelle frasi Ma
come ci hai messo solo due ore perché ti
devo pagare €600
e torniamo all'effetto Marel avete mai
sentito parlare di micro Management È
un'espressione che significa che è il
nome che si dà nel Scusate se uso
l'inglese ma le scienze della gestione
delle imprese sono di riferimento
anglosassone Mozart scriveva Adagio sui
suoi spartiti e io dico micro Management
D'altra parte se volete cercare qualcosa
su Google poi non potete cercare micro
gestione perché non troverete la stessa
qualità di risultati nel video Com'è il
micro Management è quella attitudine di
alcuni supervisori di alcuni casi di
descrivere esattamente per il minuto le
attività che loro sottoposti devono
svolgere invece di affidare delle
missioni e lasciare la libertà di
organizzarsi nel modo migliore possibile
ora tutto questo ha a che fare questo
L'ho anticipato all'inizio è una
sessione questa dedicata a chi lavora
con l'intelletto su alcuni tipi di
lavori la maggior parte delle persone in
aula Io scommetto che siano queste
persone sono le persone che lavorano su
prodotti non seriali Ok quindi chi fa il
fotografo lavora su una campagna
fotografica una volta per tutte chi fa
software lavora su un tipo di software
una volta per tutte chi fa marketing chi
fa Finanza tutte le persone che lavorano
su qualcosa che non è strettamente
seriale quindi sostanzialmente chiunque
non sia un operaio in fabbrica lavora su
aspetti non seriali del della
generazione del valore nel proprio
business
queste persone
vedono il loro lavoro di scritto da tre
aspetti fondamentali
Il primo è che le idee vengono nei
momenti più inaspettati
cosa avete pensato io magari tipo che ne
so la mattina una domenica sera Renzo
Piano viene una fantastica idea per un
progetto che deve risolvere la domenica
mattina a colazione con i propri figli
quella lì è un'ora che gli va pagata o
no
Cioè se lo paghiamo a tempo Quello è il
tempo che ho usato se io sono sotto la
doccia e mi si sblocca mi è successo Io
sono il mio background da programmatore
da sviluppatore di software Oh io facevo
delle passeggiate che erano valevano oro
passava un pomeriggio intero su un
problema non ne venivo a capo Poi andavo
in giro a giocare col gatto sul terrazzo
Wow l'illuminazione sono venuto in mente
idee di software di soluzioni sbloccato
problemi nella programmazione durante il
sonno io ho sognato tre volte mi è
successo nella vita ho sbloccato un
problema nella scrittura del mio
software mi faccio pagare quella dormita
fa ridere però non fa ridere questo è
Innanzitutto vero Quindi c'è un problema
proprio di descrizione di della sede in
cui si genera valore vado avanti
c'è anche un grosso problema di metafore
usiamo sempre questa metafora del
progetto e del cantiere dei colletti
bianchi e dei colletti blu nelle aziende
che fanno software e nelle aziende che
fanno design soprattutto nelle aziende
come dire nate alle soglie di questo
terzo millennio si parla sempre del
business e dei tecnici anche quando il
business di quelli che fanno business
dovrebbe essere fare il software che
fanno i tecnici e quindi ci sono degli
scollamenti stranissimi per cui la
metafora del progetto e poi faccio fare
a qualcun altro non funziona più se noi
diamo un libro da scrivere a Stephen
King e poi lo facciamo finire a Ken
Follett viene una schifezza
non si può più pensare che decisioni di
piccolo taglio non abbiano un effetto
strategico in certi tipi di lavoro che
sono diventati dominanti In questa epoca
vado avanti
e il vero problema è che quindi non
distinguiamo esattamente fra il valore
l'oro che estraiamo dalle miniere e il
lavoro che ci vuole per estrarre
quell'oro e noi notate bene siamo
interessati al primo non al secondo se
potessimo estrarre lo stesso oro
minimizzando il lavoro necessario per
estrarlo saremo tutti d'accordo
se potessimo minimizzare il numero di
slide che serve per fare avere successo
in una presentazione con i nostri capi
in una qualsiasi delle nostre riunioni
business saremo ben contenti di
convincere chiunque senza slide
ciò che consegniamo non è il valore di
ciò che che viene veicolato da ciò che
consegniamo e così è il tempo Il lavoro
nobilita l'uomo lo dico qui seppellite
poi quanto volete il lavoro non nobilita
l'uomo oltre ad essere una frase ormai
invecchiata di sessismo però diciamo
Facciamo così il lavoro non nobilita
l'essere umano perché il frutto del
lavoro che ci nobilita io occhio
ovviamente può servire del lavoro e del
tempo per generare quel valore ma non è
il valore per sé e separare nettamente
il valore dell'attività necessaria a
creare valore è un requisito etico
importantissimo emotivo importantissimo
manageriale è importantissimo
il motivo per cui succede tutto questo è
che siccome non sappiamo misurare il
valore di ciò che facciamo Ci
accontentiamo di dare un valore a ciò
che sappiamo misurare o dai Abbiamo
inventato l'orologio tu hai lavorato tre
ore tieni tre gettoni
oppure Ma questa cosa che hai fatto non
mi risolve il problema Eh ma io ho
lavorato tanto
Ti è mai successo un idraulico che non
ha chiuso veramente la falla un
meccanico che non vi ha riparato è
successo alzate la mano se siete mai
stati delusi da una da un consulente da
un lavoratore da un professionista
è normale e dovrebbe essere il compenso
associato alla nostra soddisfazione non
al tempo che è stato passato Sei sudato
sangue dalla fronte per risolvere un
problema senza risolverlo hai sprecato
tu il tempo tuo no io
e a questo punto visto che il nodo
cruciale diventa Ok ma che misura diamo
Quindi al valore del nostro lavoro io
sento già gli alibi quelli di cui ha
parlato prima Giovanna
Ah ma non si può misurare il valore del
mio lavoro come faccio
è vero che ci sono un sacco di lavori
che creano un valore di tipo intangibile
peraltro sono quasi tutti notate bene
perché il valore tangibile si sente che
coltiva la frutta che costruisce case
poco di più ma una borsetta di qualche
marca famosa ve lo dico io è il valore
intangibile
non soddisfa nessuna necessità Vitale
Eppure la maggior parte del Commercio si
basa su prodotti del genere Oppure
peggio ancora più di questa
dichiarazione si può dichiarare ma il
mio lavoro non ha valore che è molto
peggio cioè il punto è Se pensate Questo
è il vostro lavoro dobbiamo risolvere un
problema a Monte è inutile stare a
parlare di come lo fatturiamo siamo
d'accordo su questo tema c'è un libro
Bellissimo di David Gaber che si
intitola in inglese bullshit Jobs che
non tradurrò così con grande eleganza È
bellissimo perché si basa sul fatto che
lui è partito da una ricerca
antropologica lui era un antropologo in
cui il 38% di migliaia di intervistati
su tutto il globo diceva che il proprio
il proprio lavoro non aveva senso e
questo è il problema sociale notate bene
non è del greber che dice il tuo lavoro
non ha senso lui diceva Io non lo so ma
se lo dicono loro che lo fanno
invece di modi di creare valore Cioè
questo è importante perché poi siamo
arrivati alla conclusione il valore
quando è intangibile ed è sempre
soggettivo è comunque misurabile se il
valore di un lavoro è soggettivo basta
individuare il soggetto a cui quel
valore quel valore è dedicato e chiedere
una misura una stima di quel valore a
quella persona a quel soggetto lo fate
tutti continuamente avete comprato una
borsetta elegante avete comprato una
canna da pesca il prezzo che avete
deciso di pagare lo avete ritenuto
inferiore uguale al valore che
percepivate delle esperienze di pesca e
di passeggiate o di cene eleganti
acquistando quegli articoli Ah ma
costano poco Ah sì E quando comprate una
casa da 350 mila euro Ditemi lo fate
sulla base dei costi di quella casa
sulla base del valore percepito di
quella casa lo fate già tutti e nel
mondo del lavoro per via di una
tradizione ottocentesca di pianifico e
quindi posso misurare tutto
improvvisamente questa cosa viene
sospesa vi faccio alcuni esempi proprio
Random a caso di modi con cui si può
generare valore perché possa magari come
dire solleticare le vostre riflessioni
sul vostro lavoro si possono ridurre i
costi di qualcosa Si possono integrare
le operazioni a livello globale si può
migliorare l'efficienza si può aumentare
la rapidità con cui si incassa vedete Io
sono un ingegnere parlo di tutte cose
concrete ma potrebbe essere aumentare la
soddisfazione di una comunità di persone
ehm fare in modo che le persone siano
incazzate meno volte al mese
è tutta roba misurabile ma dice Ah ma
non è generalizzabile E che te frega
ora Questo Quindi arriva la conclusione
l'ultima slide se Noi cominciamo a
concepire il lavoro in questi termini ci
si sblocca una possibilità
importantissima capire che
mi faccio un esempio Cioè se io vi
regalo 20 euro li gradite
Siete poco convinti però Ok sì Se io vi
regalo 100 euro e vi dico restituite
meno 80 Siete contenti uguale
lo vedete che siete meno convinti ma
l'algebra Oh mica è un'opinione vi ho
regalato comunque €20 e il problema è
proprio questo il problema è che quando
noi spieghiamo che generiamo cento lire
di valore per 80 in cambio di
controvalore di pagamento compenso c'è
qualcuno che dice Eh no mi stai rubando
€80 No io ti sto regalando €20 e
qualunque prezzo inferiore al valore che
io ho generato per te è un prezzo equo
Allora vi trovate sta My space a Tik Tok
su tutti i social Se volete obiettare
contraddirmi infamarmi nei prossimi
giorni fate pure ringrazio veramente
l'organizzazione del 3dx L'Aquila perché
hanno fatto un fantastico lavoro questo
posto è bellissimo e grazie anche a voi
Ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]